in today's video i'm going to tell you
exactly how i grew my gaming channel to
1 000 subscribers
we'll talk about several of the mistakes
that i've made along the way so you
don't have to make the same ones
and we're starting right now
[Music]
swish and flick people of the internet
retro rack and tour here if we're
meeting for the first time i'm just a
dad who loves games and the stories
they tell we post videos every week here
on youtube and also stream over on
twitch
so we just hit a thousand subs and yes
i said we because i truly couldn't have
done it without your help yes
you right now watching the video you
were a part of this
but at the beginning of this video i
wanted to do something when i hit a
thousand subscribers something special
and i thought what
better thing to do than to actually try
and give back but for those of you who
don't know in my everyday job i actually
work at a library and i help people with
tech problems i also teach tech classes
so really part of what i do
every day is helping people and i know
there are a lot of you out there who
want to know how did this guy grow this
gaming channel to 1 000 subscribers
so in my journey to 1000 subs there are
really three major things that i've
learned and those three things i think
will help you get to 1 000 subs as well
if you're trying to grow a youtube
channel then the absolute number one
item you need to focus on is providing
value to your viewers you out there
watching right now when planning this
video
it's all about you guys it's all about
what can i do
to give value to someone else's life now
i'm sure you've seen this before in
videos but we're gonna dive even deeper
and really try and define
what do i mean by value here well think
about your own life we really have
two major commodities that we get to
decide how we spend
our time and our money do you have to
understand that whenever you put a
youtube video
out into the world and you ask people to
watch it you try and get people to watch
it what you're essentially saying to
them is that i think this is valuable
enough for you to give some of your time
to watch this video now it's up to you
the video creator to make sure that you
follow up on that promise and that it
is indeed worthwhile for that person to
watch and the number one way to do that
provide something of value is to provide
something that the viewers
want what are they looking for you know
just starting out on youtube i thought
hey i stream on twitch i can throw a
couple of my highlights up there
piece together some videos and hey
people will come watch
no why would anybody care about watching
me play super smash brothers i'm not a
pro player there's nothing specific
that i'm offering in terms of training
or tips there's really no value there
for you as the viewer other than hey i
made this video could you please watch
many gaming content creators start off
doing let's plays and to be clear
there's nothing
wrong with let's plays but what you have
to understand with let's plays is that
they are
so over saturated there's already
so many established creators in the
let's play genre you have to really be
honest with yourself why would somebody
choose to watch
you over these vastly popular creators
who have
years of credibility behind them to show
that they are entertaining so we're
gonna actually dive into some of my
videos here let's take a look take a
look at these two let's plays i
attempted to make both of these are from
luigi's mansion three
and the gameplay is from my twitch
channel now i worked ridiculously hard
on the editing for these it took me
hours and hours i'm not
kidding here at all took me hours to
edit these down for the precise cuts and
the funny moments that i kind of added
in now i'll be honest i still think
these are two pretty solid videos you
should go check them out
but the title offers no value
proposition
whatsoever i'm throwing my let's play
video out there up against the numerous
other content creators who are already
well established and doing the same
thing the first one here is titled
luigi's mansion
three and then in parentheses mouse
puzzle no just no now yes i could change
the title now but i wanted to leave it
up just to show you guys it's not a good
title i didn't even title it how to
solve the mouse puzzle just luigi
mention three mouse puzzle there's
nothing there that really tells you
what are you getting out of the video
now i tried to do it a little bit with
the thumbnail but the thumbnail was
the words are too tiny on the thumbnail
it's really hard to even read what i'm
saying there now around this time i had
less than
100 subs on youtube just a few short
months ago i'm leaving all these videos
up you can go back you can look through
my history
and see how many views each video has
gotten along the way
as of today even though i'm over a
thousand subscribers now uh yeah
still less than 100 views on those
videos and to be honest i think that's
fair
now let's take a look at another video i
released not even a
month after those luigi videos here it
is it's called five reasons animal
crossing new horizons is perfect
for kids and parents now right away just
from the title alone i'm communicating a
very clear value proposition here this
video has over 700 views so two things
right off the bat that make me qualified
to make that video
one i'm a parent two i played a lot of
animal crossing this summer with my son
so i had all these stories and all these
experiences to pull from that i could
share with other parents out there
i also make sure i mention that early in
the video because it helps to build my
credibility
with you the viewer now if i told you i
don't have kids and i've played animal
crossing a couple times here's a list of
why i think it's great for kids
probably not going to really care much
about that video so the title gets you
interested as a parent
and then i have to deliver on that value
proposition that i'm offering
now seeing how well that video did i
tried to stick with kind of that same
idea providing something of value that i
am uniquely qualified to do
so that led me to making this video
nintendo switch games for kids
in parentheses top 10 for 2020. you can
check the numbers here this has been one
of my most successful videos by far
amassing more than 10 000 views at the
time of this recording now again
at this time i'm still a content creator
with less than 100 subs here
so why did this video do so well for one
it's a highly relevant topic
in the midst of a global pandemic more
folks were staying inside and looking
for things to play with their kids the
switch is known as a family friendly
console and again i'm a dad with a young
son who really enjoyed watching me
playing animal crossing who then started
playing animal crossing himself
you can see where we're going here so
again it all comes back to value
ask yourself that question every single
time you make a video what
is the value proposition here am i
entertaining am i
teaching somebody how to do something am
i providing some tips
what exactly is it that you're offering
the viewer that's worthy
of their time now i know what you're
thinking out there as a gaming content
creator you hear that and you say oh
well i'm entertaining right
you can do entertaining however that one
is by far the most difficult
to do again because you're trying to
stand out in a
sea of other content creators just doing
the same thing
instead what i think you should do is
focus on one of those other ways
another way of providing value to draw
people in and then once they're there
you can entertain them as well so number
one
value start shifting the focus right now
away
from yourself and instead to the viewer
and that brings us to our second tip
which is to find
your niche or is it niche now if you're
watching
this particular video you probably
already have your overall niche of
gaming but if you're just starting out
that's not
nearly specific enough you've got to
drill down much deeper here this doesn't
mean you have to make videos on
only one thing especially if you're just
starting out experiment man don't be
afraid to get in there
try new things heck look at my videos
and you can see all the different types
of videos that i've made but your goal
of all this experimentation is to really
sort of find your groove
find where you can offer something
that's really
really unique to you so for me i mean
no surprise here i'm wearing the
gryffindor shirt today a lot of the
recent subscribers to the channel are a
result of my hogwarts legacy video so
what you have here is a specific game
that's not released yet number one
it already has a huge audience when you
consider the harry potter fandom and
then looking around on youtube there's
not a whole lot of creators making
content about hogwarts legacy so
if you look at my channel you can see
i've made animal crossing videos mario
fall guys fortnite smash bros and
honestly hogwarts legacy was another one
of those things that hey
i'm interested in i'd really like to
make some videos on this game and it
just clicked with you guys
the viewer and you all loved those
videos so much you could see what i did
i
doubled down on it said okay i'm gonna
make more hogwarts legacy videos
and so i've pretty much decided that
every week i will have at least
one hogwarts legacy video going up until
the game is released
and beyond so because i was such a huge
fan of harry potter growing up then we
have this new game coming out right now
i'm trying to build a youtube channel
i make a video on hogwarts legacy you
guys love it i love talking about it and
what do we have here i'm carving out a
niche and what's great about this is
there's nothing
shady about this it's a win-win for
everyone because it's the types of
videos that you guys are resonating with
so what do i want to do i want to make
more of the videos that you guys are
resonating with and this is something
that can certainly
change over time but i think especially
starting out
it's really important to get specific
with that targeted niche
and to provide as much value as you
possibly can within that niche
i still think i like niche better i
think the biggest thing here was the
niche
the snitch the golden snitch i think the
biggest thing here with the niche is
that you need to become
known for something you want to be known
for something on youtube when they think
oh retrorecontour that's the hogwarts
legacy guy
when they think of you out there that's
the animal crossing guy that's the
mario guy whatever it may be you need to
become synonymous
so you are instantly recognizable on the
platform and again
i'm still learning all this too be
honest with you at first i thought my
niche was going to be something about
parents and video games and helping
parents understand video games and then
i made a lot of animal crossing videos
for a while and i still love animal
crossing and may make more animal
crossing videos and those had some
success but it wasn't until i
made these harry potter videos that
things really started to take off
so number one was value number two was
niche
down and number three is to commit to
the process now i know i know you've
heard this one before
and you probably rolled your eyes you
probably rolled your eyes just now when
i said commit to the process
trust me i know how you feel part of the
reason i wanted to make this video now
right after i passed a thousand
is because all this is still so fresh in
my mind in my mind i still feel like i'm
that creator with
less than 100 subs trying to do
everything i possibly can to figure this
out so trust me when i say
i hear you i feel where you're at right
now
and i heard that tip so many times
commit to the process
and it drove me crazy so stay with me
don't let it drive you
crazy i'm gonna try and help explain it
to you here why
it drove me crazy but why it shouldn't
have drove me crazy so
the main reason that this is so
important is because going
in you just have to go ahead and
acknowledge that this
is going to be a grind sure you might
have a video that goes
viral and has a million plus views
that doesn't really happen for most
people on the platform if it does happen
for you
great ride that wave to success and
enjoy it but when you're first starting
out
try not to pay so much attention to the
views and instead
think about the processes that you're
building how many videos can you commit
to a week can you commit to one video a
week
are you so busy that no you can't do
that can you commit to one video per
month
what is it that you can fit into your
schedule to make it so that this
is something you're committed to for the
long term for most creators we all start
small
and it's going to be this very difficult
slog
up this tall tall mountain now if you're
going up a tall mountain you'll
eventually get to the top you might have
to stop and take a break you might have
to stop and slow down you might speed up
sometimes
but if you keep going you will
eventually make it to the top of that
mountain there will be days that you
want to give up
trust me where you think why am i doing
this do i really want it
and that's a question that you truly
have to ask yourself how bad
do you want it do you really want this
is it such a passionate hobby of yours
that you are willing to go through the
grind through the weeds through the
muck and mire of five views of bad
comments of no comments are you willing
to go through all that are you willing
to commit to the process
keep offering value as much as you
possibly can and keep focusing on that
niche
until you get where you want to be if
your answer is yes to that question
keep making videos always try
and be learning learn something from
every video you make learn from your
failures learn from your successes learn
what you can do better and always
keep coming back to your audience that
honestly is what has helped me more than
anything through this is thinking about
you guys the people out there watching
this now
because at the end of the day it's not
really about me i can make the greatest
videos in the world and if nobody ever
watches them then
that really doesn't mean that much to me
i want it to resonate with you guys with
people out there
so shift the focus away from yourself
and on to the people that you're trying
to make videos for you have to figure
out that audience you have to commit
to that audience and making the types of
videos they want to see now i'm still
very early at least i hope i'm still
very early in my youtube career i hope
this goes on for quite some time and
grows into something
even larger than it is now but once you
really get into that groove
once you commit to that process once you
start seeing the signs of growth
things start accelerating a little bit
faster you get that snowball rolling
down the hill
all of a sudden instead of going uphill
you're you're coasting downhill
on a lot of videos that i watched to try
and learn more about youtube
they talked about how difficult those
first 100 subs those first
200 subs 250 that those first
few subs that you get are so hard it can
take you months take you
years to get to that point and it's just
like every single sub is just
you have to fight for it so hard but
then as
you get up there a little bit higher you
start noticing it starts ticking a
little bit faster
you figure out oh wow people really
resonated with this video i'm gonna make
more videos like that
and then all of a sudden those sub
numbers they start going up up up your
views they start going up
up up i love twitch but you're only
growing on twitch when you're
on twitch unless you're doing other
things outside of that but youtube
though once you
get a video out there if it's a good
quality video then that video
is there as long as youtube exists
you will be out there and potentially
discoverable for millions and millions
of people
heck billions at this point ultimately i
would not have made it to 1000
without you guys every single person
watching this right now every sub every
person who's commented every person
who's liked
all of you out there are all part of
this so
from the bottom of my heart thank you
thank you
thank you to every single person who has
shared a video
who has liked the video who has watched
a video who has commented on a video
even if it's a mean
hurtful comment thank you for commenting
i'm so happy that you guys are enjoying
the content and i hope you continue
enjoying the content here guys and gals
this is only
the beginning of something special here
on youtube we're not gonna stop at a
thousand i'm gonna keep working as hard
as i possibly can to make videos that
you guys
wanna see i wanna create a community
where you guys truly feel
loved and welcomed and part of a family
here i know there are so many of you out
there who are going through hard times
maybe you don't have any close friends
or maybe you have friends who have
passed away family members you've lost
family members you've
never had but wish you did maybe never
had much of a family at all well
now you do and you are welcome here as
always
thank you guys so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon
people of the internet retro racing tour
here if we're meeting for the first time
what am i doing my hands i don't why am
i doing this
expecto patrol rum
in today's video i'm going to tell you
exactly how i drew my gaming channel
drew what i didn't draw anything
i can't draw i'm terrible drawing oh man
i haven't been on camera in a while
jeez bear with me guys it seems
only yesterday that your mother and
father win here buying their
first bonds we'll give it a wave